[Music]
oh what is your favorite position
oh easy three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
how long is your relationship did you
wait to have sex
so like three hours um i'll let you
answer first because your answer is
always wrong
in my head it was three days three days
uh
but three times that we've hung out
three times that we hung out okay
yes yes i think it was a month our
relationship we took really seriously
that
we should learn to love each other first
before having sex not making
sex the reason why we're in love with
each other well we still haven't
we are waiting until marriage when we
first
began talking or began dating we both
knew immediately that that's where we
stood
i am lucky to find someone who was also
willing to wait
do you use any toys if so which ones
vibrators collar my favorite i really
want him to learn how to you know like
tie me up and rope if i
had known like that was going to be part
of my journey i probably would join the
boy scouts or something you know
we're fine with using them but we don't
need more spice i think that would be a
lot it would be like a lot
we don't use any toys i would say i'm
old-fashioned
i'm all for it if you if you feel good
and that and that helps
so if anyone can sponsor us
personally i would be open to it in the
future but i think in the
beginning like i want to try it natural
in a sense did you ever have periods
of low desire or less sex and how did
you get through those or bounce back
i think we're currently in one now yeah
we've been together
two years actually and we celebrated by
moving in together
i did realize that after we've moved in
we've had a lot less sex
i noticed that too but we've been really
busy like the furniture
finals planning vacations you look sad
so i'll text him in the morning time
even though he's in the bed right next
to me
normally like the cat emoji or like
something just letting him know like i
want some you know making me feel wanted
and now
you know return the favor make her feel
wanted and you know just building up
anticipation throughout the day
throughout the week
i had a low sex drive when shannon was
pregnant
and it wasn't because i didn't desire
you we just
were limited in the type of sex that we
could have at that time
although we still had sex it wasn't like
it wasn't the best
yes but i think a rule that we set
really early on which i don't know if we
ever verbalized but
i don't ever turn you down and you don't
ever turn me down yeah
even during pregnancy sex when i knew
that you weren't enthusiastic if i came
on to you
you would still be like okay like you
know i didn't do it like that not like
that but
what is your favorite position oh wait
ready yeah i'm ready three two one
[Laughter]
three two one
what did you say you on top we googled
up what is the laziest sex position
and it was the one that we do all the
time and we're like wow we are
really lazy do you ever have the desire
to have sex with someone else
i do uh i think we all do
but we just never act upon it no not at
all
absolutely yes the desire for sure
if anyone answers that question
otherwise they're lying
we had a period where we like got rid of
our urges and
we allowed each other to like talk to
other people but only through texting
because if everything's just online it's
not really real
it's just for fun and then i like that
about us because the whole thing is all
about
compromises we're always compromising we
we meet in the middle a lot
yeah okay are there things you don't
like that you've never
told your partner i personally don't
like
when something is over exaggerated maybe
uh comments about like size or comments
about like how something feels
i like it to be for for me it's a very
honest
process no we have this thing where he
just he gets
too into it too excited and i don't
quite
get to get there because he he i know
he does he uh you know he finishes
his work first and he does a good job at
like
making sure i'm satisfied too i may get
up and leave
or like randomly yeah like if we like
finish
like one round or something i may go get
some water or something
and then i may end up walking past the
tv and like yeah cause you
did you you said you had what now was it
oh add yeah he has 80d
i look at sex is like a like a marathon
not necessarily a sprint
and so i look at it it's like you can
pause and stop so like i mean it's pause
here
pick it right back up a few minutes
later i'll be wanting to go all night
long i'm like there is no there is no
time
i was coaching no paul you should have
got water before you started
how long does sex normally last i don't
keep track
i mean on a good day yes 10 minutes
um or maybe more sometimes we don't do
foreplay
we go we just normally straight to the
poi done and done
he normally gives me a good 30 minutes
and i also would say it depends
on if she had been drinking or not or we
have a drink
37 minutes 37 minutes
i think so we actually have a video of
us having sex let's see how long it is
i'm not going to show it i'm going to
say
oh it's only 13 43 but i think we
stopped recording
okay so then if you add that plus to 20
minutes we're right on time
you did it right do you both finish
every time
i finish everything you do you know what
you have
he makes sure as i finish every single
time first like he makes sure i'm taken
care of and then he worries about
himself so i appreciate that
yes yes that's something that was not
prioritized with me
and something that he does a really good
job of making sure it's really
unfortunate though that
in a straight couple relationship the
female typically always has to finish
first that's just constantly okay let's
like get you off and then you get to go
kind of thing
my best orgasm is yet
to come and i feel like only i
can give it to me it's just not it's
nothing about him it's just
my body and as in credit is so
difficult for me to
[Music]
do she always tells me how and this way
and do that way but then sometimes
it doesn't work or i get you know too
into it and then
i i feel like bad sometimes too because
i feel like i'm selfish in that part
even like when i'm just doing it to
myself i feel shameful when i
hit orgasm and i just like a natural
feeling that today i still don't
understand why
okay do you care if your partner watches
porn
um i do uh
personally i don't think it is okay to
watch
it would definitely hinder our
relationship and our connection
especially since we haven't had sex i
want to be
the only woman that he looks at you know
from
everything that we know about porn and
any study done
i just i don't see any healthy benefits
to it i don't care if she watches porn
i enjoy watching porn together that's
pretty fun everyone should try it
seriously
some people need it yeah we both watch
porn
um i don't even show each other the porn
watch like did you see this one
i don't understand the stigma behind it
too because it's just like everyone
everyone
watches it i feel like porn often can be
just used as a tool to like fix
a problem or a stress or something to be
integrated into your life that has
nothing to really do
with uh sexual like satisfaction
it's more of just something to do to
feel different i've struggled with that
my whole life
is using things to feel better instead
of actually dealing with whatever the
problem is at hand are you comfortable
with me okay
so there was a period where he was
single for like a year and a half and i
guess
that's where his sex his porn addition
came
in my tech drive is pretty high i must
say yeah it just happened and then
that's
the but i yeah i don't watch that much
anymore
this one day i was going through his
phone and like
i saw that like like porn and i was like
did you download this
that's when i was like tell me about
this like he's been having that same
problem for like a whole year
and then at that time i felt like oh
okay so i've been with you for a whole
year and
somehow i didn't know about this i
didn't feel like he was cheating on me
on any kind i don't think that watching
porn means cheating i just
feel like i deserve to know if my
partner is
you know and because it makes me feel
like oh am i not giving you enough
i wasn't completely happy about it but
after we communicate
we're fine now so yeah see does your
partner's body count matter to you
why and why not no it doesn't matter to
me
definitely we were dating there were a
lot of people especially people who
didn't know us that would like to assume
that i was dating him for money
my mom even thought i was dating him for
money i'm broke
when he opened up to me i didn't realize
like how many people he has experience
with which it didn't bother me because
he was really transparent about it when
i asked i never thought about it we
never talked about it
yeah i actually am attracted to a woman
with experience and for me i have no
room to shame because my body count is
something yeah why jared laughed is
because he
lied to me about his partners so he told
me i think he said seven no one should
believe
anybody that says well i did that's just
not a right number and then this year
for the first time he was like
you know it's not seven right and i was
like no i didn't
i don't know i don't care but i was just
like why would you lie about that
there's so much pressure about body
count
and i think when you have a high body
count there's like a stigma that gets
placed on you
maybe rightfully so but i didn't want
that to interfere with what we had going
on
i talk about sex for a living why would
i of all people be like
oh you've had sex with don't you make
such a big deal about it being seven
because it was
crazy such a big deal i'm talking first
on this one
so we've had this conversation before
where it was like
i don't know over 100 for your body
count probably i don't know
he doesn't know something like that so
he's been sober for
seven years going on eight and so a lot
of it was like i don't know what you're
doing
you know like you're [ __ ] up my kind
of situation at least half i can't even
like really
recall the names and stuff i mean it may
have may have
bothered me in the beginning not for
like oh this is how many
people's lives you've been a part of but
more so of like i felt
out experienced kind of thing i
struggle with emotional connection and
sex
and that is one thing that actually i
don't even think i've
told it to you but that has been
i can't compare anything yeah i can't
compare anything to the way that i feel
with you emotionally
in sex i just can't all right
what does consent look like for youtube
communication communication just being
open with each other and what
we like and don't like you know in the
middle of it i'll ask if like
everything's you know like oh this is
still fine yeah
he'll ask me if i want to use toys or
anything he'll
check in with me see if my legs are
hurting or anything or if my back's okay
so he checks in with me a lot consent
should always
be present just because you're in a
long-term committed relationship doesn't
mean you you
won't have to ask the other person if
they're okay anymore i would say it's
the most important thing
about sex yeah that's something that i
wish i was
even i i've been raped twice in both
those situations were in relationships
which is really rare
and what happens is that what you
realize
is that like consent is not just a
one-time thing
um consent continues like he asks for
consent
every single time throughout the entire
process of it
which is something i've never had before
that's that's a really really cool thing
to happen it makes me feel really
validated and really good
especially after sex it's like he does a
really good job of just making you feel
safe
and i wish like all guys knew that i
wish all guys were just taught that
so i'm really just really thankful that
he's there and he
relearned and re-taught and all that
[Music]
yeah
you